point one opening huh this is the
awakening this is the beginning of the
third season and just from the first
shot you're immediately going what the
fuck and it's a good way to start off I
think it's a very good way to start off
because we have an questioning whether
or not he failed and how he can redeem
himself I mean it's not even really a
matter of did he fail he feels he failed
Eve they pretty much know is he failed
and is trying to find some redemption
and on the other end Zuko is now getting
all the rewards because his sister lied
and said he was the one that destroyed
the avatar when really to find out it's
a means to make sure that he really is
dead so either Zuko will chase after him
again to make sure that he's dead or the
avatar will still be alive in Zuko will
be claim to failure again so either way
she wins what a great villain um so yeah
we have a gala stuff going on this one
the they have the fire the Fire Nation
ship on their side they come across a
tower Fire Nation ship that obviously is
being run by mark hamil
if you listen that I'm like that's Mark
Hamill or an unbelievable sound of logic
which is possible bond just like Mark
Hamill so on top of that we see Mark
Hamill finally in this we see the the
Fire Lord and what I like about his
design is that I think you're really
imagine he's gonna have like a scar
something like that'd be really ugly
they're keeping him as out of the whole
time he's actually like this very sort
of feminine looking man he's actually
like you know kind of a good-looking guy
I mean everything about this actually he
almost looks gentle um and the only
giveaway really is the eyes the eyes
were sort of these piercing eyes are a
little bigger than the head and they're
a touch wider than everyone else is
designed so yeah it's a good design it's
always sort of when when I would hear
about Sauron you know and lower the
Rings before he became whatever that
metal bullshit wasn't Fellowship of the
Ring when he was human
sort of what I imagined he looked like
he was very he wasn't this evil looking
thing he was actually this very
welcoming thing this very peaceful thing
this very tempting thing uh that would
trick everybody you know or sort of like
Loki in a sense they make him sort of
like this very you know he's not like an
ogre yeah and the Avengers I mean he's
this very sleek smooth looking guy about
4th of July right now gives you an idea
early I shoot these um zombie here stuff
exploding that's you know just
firebenders outside so I like the design
of this guy I thought it was a very I
thought was very smart to go that route
then the big ugly monster so I thought
that was a very smart choice we also
have something interesting I didn't know
how to feel about this you got Katara's
reunite with her father and she's just
kind of a jerk to him and you find out
later it's because she resents the fact
that he left even though she knows he
had to and it's or comes to this head at
the end of the episode um very well this
actress does his wonderful read on this
part I mean that probably her most
emotional I've seen a scenery on this
show does a great job but strangely that
not to say I don't get what they were
saying with it but I don't know the
emotions early on the way she was so
confrontational with him was felt right
I didn't feel like her I didn't feel
like she would be quite this I hate to
use the word immature of a kind of quite
this immature with the emotions um
because she seemed smarter than this she
seemed a little bit more balanced than
that and you can understand her being
kind of resentful she even says at the
end I don't know why I feel this way
it's just now that I've come to you
again it's these feelings really really
are surging and I can't help them and
that's cool that's a very good
explanation it's just those actual
feelings I felt were not represented
properly early on I felt it was too much
like he did something currently that
upset at her it wasn't sort of like more
just sort of as closed off as it wasn't
unangan and I that didn't feel right to
me um but
yeah like I said when she actually opens
up to him I thought that was a very
nicely done sort of confrontation really
more with herself than with her dad so
that was good the you got some fun
action with the
fighting the ships there and stuff and
it's good it's good to see Zuko back I'm
trying to think what's the other and
what hair looks strange but uh uh you
know I see everything I like the fact
that he has to come to grips with the
idea that he has to be dead he has to
act like he doesn't exist anymore after
what he feels is his biggest failure I
mean with just what a here's a guy who
our kid who's just felt like he has
constantly let people down in the past I
mean he's done all these could and it's
still failing it's still failure and
that's just the toughest thing for
anybody to go through when you try your
hardest and it still blows up in your
face and you can really see that turmoil
in him that he does not want to be kept
silent because everyone is probably
seeing him as a failure most importantly
he's seeing himself as a failure so you
can understand why he would so quickly
want to rush out and try to take on the
fire nation just by himself not let
anyone else get involved he's tired of
other people getting hurt I mean it's
just even though he's done a lot of
great things that's not what he sees he
sees failure after failure after failure
so I thought this was a good coming to
grips of that this was a really nice it
this was a really nice way of showing
what he has to deal with after being out
for so long on top of that he's just
been out of commission and like I said
he has hair now and he wakes up on this
fire nation ship what the hell so they
they I think for him they really
captured that just that you're that pure
fear that you will not be able to fix
everything um that not only have you
failed but you failed you failed not
just yourself but everybody whether they
realize it or not do you realize it so
that's the ultimate failure
and him coming to grips with that was
very good I like him going to the
volcano and destroying the glider I'm
gonna miss that glider uh you know I saw
attending where he sets it up and lets
it burn ever so surly yeah but maybe
they'd have something stronger there but
then the more thing about like yeah that
gliders been like there from the
beginning it's gonna be weird just that
being gone just there being no more
glider so maybe he'll make enough make
another one I don't know but also he has
to realize that when he finally comes
back it's gonna be such an awesome big
thing and everyone's gonna go I thought
he was dead oh my god so um yeah I that
that's gonna be awesome when that
finally happens and obviously this
chapter it's called fire so he's gonna
learn fire that's what I want to see at
the end of this one I want him to just
he puts down the staff he looks at the
lava on the volcano somehow doesn't get
burned but if he looks at the love of
the volcano turns to the camera and says
I have to learn firebending and then you
want the screen to whiten on the credits
but I'm sure they're saving that um
because that's always the thing you did
not want to learn firebending I'm sure
that's gonna be like the big dilemma now
is how much can he learn it without
going too far going to you know too much
of the dark side whatever um so yeah a
good good start to this episode I always
like it when the good guys are now the
underdogs and and they're hiding and
they have to slowly be building up um so
yeah I look forward to where that goes
and then ice cream truck
that's a fucking ice cream truck fifty
logs over later